I
Come from Earth a planet about laws
What master do you serve master? Do I serve what am I supposed to say Jesus?
When the ellipse wants to settle God throws a stone at us. Yeah me and
rejoice
Party this rock. I will build my church
You have had the privilege of being saved by the great title. How is humanity saved?
if it's not allowed to
evolve
Fulfilling prophecy. I hate this prophecy
In the Marvel Cinematic Universe who is portrayed as the enemy of our soul I
am
Hey everybody
welcome to
LED live where we are going to expose some darkness with the light of Christ and you guys aren't going to want to miss this
One because we're gonna talk about the Marvel Universe and they're in the game
And if you're a Christian, I believe that there is a reason why the world has totally become obsessed with this movie
1.2 billion dollars in its opening weekend is out of control find out on this episode of
LED light
You guys have you ever seen a Marvel film bro? Yes you probably have
But you know
I think that they were brilliant in the way that they were
literally roping together all of these stories and collecting sort of audiences in each one of the categories and then
Converging them all together in a final story. I mean it was just a brilliant idea for a company
Yeah, kind of like a flavor for everybody. Yeah, you're gonna identify one of these comic characters probably right exactly exactly
Do you guys remember from replacement guns one when we had the artist that was talking with Grant Morrison
And he basically said listen, this is a recreation of the Bible. Yeah guys remember that I
Really believe there's a reason why we're seeing so many biblical references
And I mean, it's pretty shocking when you kind of wrap your head around it. So I'm excited to present this for you guys
All right. All right
So in order to kind of basically wrap your head around this
We're gonna go all the way back to ten years ago the very first iron man
now there's a lot of peril that iron man actually has
Biblical parallels that almost kind of pin him as the savior you guys will check this out. There's even
Comments that are made in the film that are directly taken from the Bible such as this one
Render under Caesar that which is Caesars, which is a line that's directly taken from
From Jesus right? So
Here it is in Matthew 22:21
It says they said unto Him Caesars and then he said unto them render unto Caesar that which is Caesars
So this is when Jesus was getting confronted with the Pharisees and they were asking him
You know, who do we pay our money to and he quotes this exact line, so I found that kind of interesting
Yeah, there's another scene here where in the very beginning of the movie. Tony Stark is
Describing how his company is really a company
That's that's making weapons to destroy large entities and he titled this one with a biblical name
Well your consideration
the chair
As you could notice he holds his arms out and sort of a christ-like pose right now who destroyed Jericho, is that a devil
No, no, that was that was Jesus, right?
So there's this parallel here once again with with him being like a Christ type when he became Iron Man
This is the first time that that he like almost dies
literally and they take him to a cave and that's where they put that little thing on his chest and
Which saves his life and here's a here's him inside of the cave
I've seen many moons like that. It might been and we call them the walking dead
So he makes a reference that he's like The Walking Dead which is another christ-like type reference, right?
But he's in the cave for three months
Being becoming Iron Man, right and he comes out of the cave
Literally blowing people away and destroying them right so we start to see now a stark contrast
Of if this is really like a Christ type or a savior of the world
Is that really something that Jesus would do right come out of the cave and start destroying life
The Bible says this in John 10:10 that if thief cometh not but to steal and to kill and to destroy
I am come that they might have life and that they might have it more abundantly
The very purpose of Jesus was not to hurt and destroy people
In fact, he spent most of his time running around healing people and helping them
Right right when you analyze the comic books
there is
Some references even in the comic drawings that he's just like Jesus
In fact, this is Tony Stark here. And as you notice, he's in a very Jesus like pose
This is actually a sculpture of of Jesus and Mary and other Koons. It's not a coincidence and I even took the
Comic book here and overlaid it. I mean look at this. He's even literally in the exact same pose. That is purposeful
That's what I was noticing here and gesture is identical identical
so I believe that this is definitely purposeful to make him like a Christ type right but
The bad guy in the movie as we start to
Uncover who these bad guys are that that that all the Marvel Universe is always fighting against guys that want to take over the world
Or that want to destroy the entire world or half the universe, right?
They have a lot of similarities to god or gods Judd gods gods government
So the bad guy in the first iron man, his name is Obadiah. I don't want a body count to be absolutely as well
we visit where iron mongers we make weapons my name on the side of the building what we do keeps the world from falling into
chaos
So basically the bad guy Obadiah says what we do for a living is try to prevent the world from falling into chaos
Right by destroying things with these weapons that are called the Jericho weapons and stuff right now
When you look at Obadiah Stane?
Obadiah is actually hebrew for slave of god the biblical theophoric names
means servant of God or worshipper of Yahweh now find that really interesting but the bad guy is
Literally the servant or or slave of God and the Bible
talks about
Jesus as being the servant of God, right isaiah 42:1
This is a prophetic interpretation of Jesus behold my servant whom I uphold mine elect in whom my soul delighteth
I have put my spirit upon him and he shall bring forth judgment to the Gentiles
So I think that is not by chance that they named him literally servant of the Lord
So let's move to Iron Man 2. Okay, so
In order for this to be a true statement to basically say that they're they're literally warring God against the devil
But they're kind of flipping the model around there has to be consistency throughout all of them. Wouldn't you agree?
So it's not like just one film that you're going to notice this we've got to see this thing throughout a lot of different films
in Iron Man -
Here he is there
once again giving you the imagery that Tony Stark is sort of a
Christ type and here he's offering to save the world through the of peace
He's in a court scene and he's being questioned in front of the judge
I mean Jesus was in court being quested questioned in front of the judges too. And
We know that Jesus is called the Prince of Peace, right? So listen to the scene
We're safe America is secure you want my property you can't have it. But I did you a big favor. I
Have successfully privatized world. Peace. So here he is bringing world. Peace. That's kind of his mission
Facts a mission that Jesus had you have heard it said you shall love your neighbor and hate your enemy
But I say until you love your enemies bless
Those that curse you do good to those that hate you and pray for those who spitefully use you and persecute
You right Jesus was the Prince of Peace that he came to really share how we were supposed to live peacefully
So if if God if the enemy is like God
And the good guys like Jesus that seems like a good thing. Right, right
So on the surface when you watch these and you kind of recognize okay, there's some Jesus type parallels
But when you really analyze his character his character is totally different than Jesus, right? He's totally this rich
Narcissist it was Jesus. Rich. No, did he come to the earth in it all of his wealth? No way
So who is the rich one in the world that can promise you anything, right? So
even though he's
Set up to be like Jesus that's more of an antichrist type character. So here the bad guy in here Ivan
You can see things written on the wall. It says Tony Stark is here to save the world and
Ivan is here talking about Tony Stark. Listen to what he says
Bleep
People was
So he says if you could make God bleed
People will cease to believe in him
right
But that's kind of the whole angle that that the Iron Man 2 is taking he's trying to hurt Tony Stark and Iron Man
Here's the picture. Tony Stark is here to save the world
Once again that imagery we see popping through this was fascinating about that statement. He just made is
God did bleed
you know and
Instead of people not believing in him people believed in him because of that
So this scene right here Ivan is in prison Tony Stark comes to visit him in prison, which I think is very interesting
and
The dialogue that happens back and forth really kind of starts to begin to show you a picture of who the Iron Man really is
you go from
Family of thieves and butchers
And now that were guilty men
Try to rewrite your own history
And you'll forgive pull the legs they start family as destroyed
Speaking of Thieves. Where did you get this design?
My father I'm Donna Parker. Oh, no, honey
My father there is in human life
So it's very interesting that he says he came because of his father and Tony Stark goes
I've never heard of him before and he goes my father is the reason you're alive now can the devil make that statement?
No, he cannot right. In fact, the very reason all life exists is because God allows it
Right most of asteroid, right?
And he says to Tony Stark you come from a family of thieves and murderers, right?
You can't you can't make that comment towards God
He's not a thief right the devil is known as the thief so there's some imagery here that really he he has
Some sort of Christianity and sort of a twisted bent way he wears a maltese cross
He has these whips and he looks like he's been whipped himself liber
His name is yeah, white bird on his shoulder right very interesting kind of like the Holy Spirit right long hair
I mean, there's some parallels here that are very strange
Now John 8:44 says you belong to your father the devil and you want to carry out your father's desires
He was a murderer from the beginning. So they were twisting your idea and perception of who's who in the story
But listen to how Tony Stark gets psychologically analyzed and listen to how they describe him
He's reading his analyzation of himself. Mr. Stark displays textbook narcissism
So he displays textbook narcissism, right? You can't attribute that to God. God is so others focused
in fact
He loved the world so much he gave a son to die for those that don't even care about him
Right the opposite of narcissism. It's the devil. That's
Narcissistic, so let's talk about Iron Man 3
In the storyline of Iron Man 3 and when they play the trailers for you
They don't show you exactly who the bad guy is
so they set it up that this particular character that Ben Kingsley played is
The bad guy and so the voice that you hear is going to be his voice. Listen to how he
addresses people and see if this rings any Christian alarm bells
Some people call me a terrorist
I consider myself a teacher
so he
addresses people as
ladies
Children sheep, right? Those are all names that Jesus uses to describe our relationship with him, right?
We have the Bride of Christ
we are his sheep and we are literally children of God, right and he says
Some people consider me to be a teacher, right? Jesus was a teacher. So there are some strange parallels with him and
Christianity now in this second trailer that they put put out for this movie
There are flashing scenes that's happening all throughout the movie and the camera
Flashes through a scene where you see this character that Ben Kingsley plays he raises his arms up in the air
and
So I went back and I paused it and I looked at what it is
says on his robe because every time something is written on the screen that tells me that some time a director had to
Make a decision Hey write that on there. No, no nothing
No words are gonna automatically I can go to a store and buy this that's right. That's right
So this is actually made so if you'll notice right here
What does it say right here for a day everything we redeemed through blood who's who's redeemed through blood?
We are right. That's that's something that describes our
Salvation through Jesus really and they're putting this on the bad guy and he's got his arms outstretched like in a christ-like pose
We are redeemed through blood and in fact, the Bible has lots to say about this Ephesians. 1:7 says in whom you have
Redemption through his blood the forgiveness of sins and according to his riches in Grace and Isaiah 44
22 says I have swept away your offenses like a cloud your sins like the morning mist
Return unto me for I have redeemed you
I think it's beautiful that we are redeemed through Christ, you know
But they're painting him as he's the evil one, right? But the twist in Iron Man 3 is
This isn't even really the real bad guy. In fact, they put him as
Actor who's in prison, but he's really just an actor. He's not even like a real bad guy
So it's almost like even just another little jab at God like oh, yeah, you came into this criminal world
But you're not really, you know a sinner and you're not really a bad guy
I find that it's kind of an interesting parallel. But all of these guys that are in prison
they want to hear him do his like little dark voice that he always does so listen to the scene and see if you see
Any Christian parallels with this I me and the boys was just wondering if you could do
Do the voice?
Fletcher
It's not something I can just turn home. I'm not your meat puppet
all very well
And you'll never see me coming
Thief in the night, right
Wow
Thief in the night seriously and he's talking to other criminals, you know what I mean? And
one thing that's kind of interesting is when I actually was looking for this up in in the
In the internet just to even find this clip
they titled this clip hail to the king and I think that in the film they actually even call him the king which is very
Interested in aim of the chapter on the aim of the years exactly. So let's talk about the Thor
Okay, so moving on different one. We showed this in replacement gods too
So this will be just kind of a little bit of a refresher
you guys have probably seen this before but this scene is a
Scene between Thor and its father and this is when the very beginning when they introduced Thor to the world
Listen to the language that they use even here
I have sacrificed much to achieve. Peace
Who you are arrogance and stupidity you have opened these peaceful realms and innocent lives to the horror and
Devastation
You are a vain greedy cruel boy
Please open your eyes
No, this is
Where it comes up, so what do you guys notice right off the bat? It's just like Satan just like Satan, right?
He's having a conversation with with his father in heaven
His father says you're the you're the vain greedy cruel boy who traded peace for war
Who's who's the epitome of vain greed?
cruelty that literally traded peace for war
Was cast down to earth in a bolt of lightning, right?
do you remember the story when Jesus was talking with the disciples and the disciples all came to him and they said
Yes, we have power over the demons and we can cast them out right remember that story and Jesus goes no no, no
Don't don't gloat at that don't be excited about that because he says in Luke 10:18
I saw Satan fall like lightning from heaven
That's why the devil is always described as this bolt of lightning ACDC bolt of lightning, you know
the devil's children always like, you know kind of describe their
Occult through a bolt of lightning. It's because of this verse so in Thor Ragnarok
There is a very interesting scene. Once again, we see some crazy parallels. It's come to my attention
You don't know who - God Jesus a bad guy in this case. His Thor's sister. I am hella
Odin's firstborn
Commander the legions of as goth now. I want you to observe something right off the bat. Look at her crown
It is literally in the design of a crown of thorns
Go back to I've ever change you have genitive
And there's this scene where she is walking back into her throne room Thor sitting on the throne
you can see this crown of thorns going back into her head and
She has this very interesting dialogue with Thor check this out
it seems our fathers solution to every problem was to cover it up or
To cast it out. I
Find it very interesting that she's literally saying our father's way of dealing with things is to just cover it up
But see that's what God does God's
Atoning blood through Jesus Christ
Covers our sins and listen to what Thor says it wouldn't cost it out
We already saw that he was the one cast out which is a representation of Lucifer I
Want to point something out right here?
if you notice that this symbol in the ground where she is
Standing is the symbol of the Trinity you see it on a lot of Bibles
That was put here on purpose not by mistake
And then one day he decided to become a benevolent king
to foster peace to protect life
The fact that she's saying that her father the one that cast Thor out is a benevolent
King and he wants to protect life and be peaceful
Once again is a description of God
Difference between us. I know'd ins firstborn the rightful heir the savior of ASCO and you're noting
The fact that she says she is the firstborn the rightful heir to the throne and the
Savior is once again another parallel to Jesus. Now. Let's talk about guardians of the galaxy
Okay, so totally different movie
Right, you're starting to see that the heroes from Marvel share a lot in common with Satan now Ironman we brought this up earlier
right more of like an antichrist type character, but he's this rich
Narcissist, I mean that's more of like the devil's character traits than it is like Jesus
So guardians of the galaxy is a story where you have
Criminals in the universe that are going to save the world, right?
They're the cast out people the the one that everybody hates, right?
Well, and they're the ones that are going to begin to save the universe now, I found this really interesting
Listen to the language that they talk about
Describing the villain in this series
You saw how that high priest is talking down to us, so
The villain is a high priest, right?
Here's the villain of the story all decked out in gold and you'll notice as you watch this clip
Everything is in order. Everything is perfectly like
symmetrical right and
Her name is the High Priestess. Listen how this guy?
Interacts with her the delay Admiral High Priestess the batteries they are
Exceptionally combustible and could destroy the entire fleet. Our concern is their slight against our people
We hired them and they steal from us
Which is heresy of the highest order
All command modules
So as you notice once again a raid in a very very interesting pattern everything is very orderly
I mean, it's the same sort of thing if you look if you watch Star Wars
It's like the rebellion is sort of chaotic. You look at the Republic everything very in order
right, so a very similar type setup that we got going on here and
They're called the sovereigns which are in it, right?
Because the word sovereign me anyone want to take a slab ruler the ruler, right?
In fact, this is the sovereign this is her her throne notice
There's light streaming out of it. Right god is the very source of light in in in heaven. I see it within you
fear
Jealousy betrayal, this is all. Juvie
Of this weakness
Right heresy High Priestess, but you see the little jab that the high priest is really a girl
I mean, you know what? I mean? It's just like a little tiny like slam that they got to do their
Sovereign means if you look it up on the internet supreme ruler even a monarch
causing our possessing supreme or ultimate power you can't
Attribute that to the devil the devil does not have supreme power over God
Only God has supreme power in the universe from a Christian perspective. Right? Right. You're gonna hear a phrase
That's very interesting
And when you hear the phrase, I actually hear this phrase pop up in a lot of Marvel movies
So here's the phrase to make you do that. You'd have to be the greatest pilot in the universe lucky for us
So in order to make it out of here you would have to be the greatest I am
Right something you'll see pop up actually in a few different stories Avengers age of Ultron
Similar type set up. You've got some
Ultimate power that was created and the ultimate power that was created
is this this being this digital bean called Ultron and he's actually
Created to be a peaceful being and to cause peace in the universe
What is this? Hello. I am Jarvis
You are ultra a global peacekeeping initiative designed by mr. Stark. This feels wrong. I'm a peacekeeping program
Created to help the Avengers. They don't get the mission. Give me a second. Peace in our time
Once again another parallel that's happening here on that poster
Since Ironman is the one like Christ to get his hands
Exactly and he has something on his hands. I mean that's something I didn't even notice before but yeah, you're right
He has these these marks on his hands and he shoots light out of them. I mean
We know Jesus will have the marks forever in his hands even throughout eternity for us to remember that by so yeah
Very interesting that you pointed that out. So Ultron is the ultimate evil in this particular series
Here's when the Marvel characters are actually meeting Ultron for the first time so question
Ultron is
Created a certain way. Yes forward piece
Becomes evil. What's the explanation?
that he basically
saw
everything that everyone was doing and
He then thought that the path to peace was literally to exterminate these people
So in other words, he thought that he had a better way
than the Creator
Exactly Joe and very interesting that it's the Marvel Universe that created him
So that's a very Gnostic theme when you have these these Demiurge
All these little sub gods and they created a god like Sophia and it was Sophia
That was the evil God and was the one that was cast out there flipping the model upside down
This is coming at you from a very Gnostic perspective
So here they're meeting Ultron for the very first time and listen to the verbage that is even used in this scene
I'm on a mission
What mission?
peace in our time
I'm on a mission peace in our time. So his ultimate goal is to create. Peace. How could you be worthy?
You're all killers and his pathway to peace he believes is to wipe out
Anybody that is fighting on the other side of the fence right now?
Why is that significant in a Christian worldview Christ is gonna come back with fire and destroy the wicked
the reset of the kingdom of
Perfection because just like Ultron right here right sin is infectious
Infecting the entire universe, right? So, how is God gonna deal with it? Mister? He's gonna destroy it, right?
That is a crazy parallel that is happening. Even in here interesting. Like I'm assuming these are his warriors that are
Crashing through and it's like everybody winds up looking like Iron Man, you know
It's like they're created in that image. Like this is as good as it can get, you know, you know, you're duplicating that model, right?
There's a lot of biblical terminology that is thrown out here and you will see this, but I want to read to you
Psalms 85 8 says I will listen to what God the Lord says he promises peace to his people and faithful servants
Right. The Bible describes God is is is
being the
Instigator of peace right? We're engaged in a war
We know that there's obviously a battle going on but God is the god of peace. So listen to how the Avengers
Talk with Ultron and you'll start to hear some biblical terminology
How is humanity?
saved if it's not allowed to
evolve
only one path to peace
The extinction
And strings, but now I'm free
So an interesting scene, he's basically saying there's one path to peace the
Extinction of this group that's kind of like the rebels right? So to say and they kill him
He dies
But really he goes into everyone else now
speaking Christianity, right God is literally he died, but he
Literally as going into his followers, right? We're supposed to open our hearts and invite Jesus into our lives
So once again another interesting kind of parallel Ultron says something right here in this scene that you might find very biblical
On this rock. I will build my church
So
Upon this rock. I will build my church in this movie, right?
Who said that who said that Jews Jews Jesus Christ?
Right and I say unto thee that thou art Peter and upon this rock
I will build my church and the gates of Hell shall not prevail against it
so very interesting the very line that Jesus uses is used here and
Ultron meets up with his people that he's trying to deceive that are part of the Avengers side and
They're meeting in a church. Very interesting, right?
This church is in the exact center of the city
The elders decreed it so that everyone could be equally close to God. I like that the geometry of belief
Very interesting. I'm sitting on a throne in the very center of church and nedelin
What's on his head? And that's how you get close to God?
He's kind of got like a towel shawl thing over his head almost like a cheese, right, you know, very interesting sitting on the throne
So listen to the language that's still being used is that why you've come
The Avengers I've come to save the world
But when he's asked why have you come?
literally come right it was created remember, but but why have you come that's language that's used in heaven and
He says I've come to save humanity. That's the very idea of Jesus, right?
in fact
The devil doesn't want to save you he wants to destroy you so you can't fit that model into the devil
Now this particular character, his name is vision and the Avengers also create him to give him life. Listen to the language
that's that's
Used in this particular scene when he meets the Avengers for the first time you think I'm a child of Ultron
You're not
I'm not altering. I'm not Java silent
I am
Kind of interesting then here once again, we see the same phrase
I am and you'll notice this kind of pop up with a lot of them, right?
What is I am?
It's good the name of God right? When Moses asked what am I supposed to call you?
He said I am that I am right and so here he's saying I'm not a child of Ultron
Listen to the verbage that's used there. Right? We are the children of God
I mean, even the way that they refer to people who follow Ultron is like what gods call it followers are called
Right, so also here he's sitting there
Describing what the plan of action is to beat Ultron. I find this very interesting. Listen to this. I
Don't want to kill Ultron he's unique and he's in pain
But that pain will roll over the earth
So he must be destroyed
Every form he's built every trace of his presence on the net. So, what did you just hear?
He didn't want to destroy him. He wants to destroy
Everything that he stands for the image of him, right?
He wants to utterly change every form every thought every idea
Because that's the ultimate way to destroy someone right even if they're there in your presence
but to destroy who that image is to people that's the best way to beat them because it turned your
opinion of them like so now the whole world is coming against this person because they believe that their characters twisted, you know,
But it's exactly like what the devil is doing with God right in the Dark Ages the devil knew the more Christians
He killed the more they popped up, right so all of a sudden he goes
Well, I can't just kill him because all of a sudden they repopulated like crazy
What I can do is destroy the image of God in them and he's taken over
Christianity and
Twisted it, right? So I found this pretty interesting that this is literally the devil's plan
To diss God's image in your life now
Listen to this even when the earth starts to settle
God throws a stone at it and believe me he's winding up. All right. He said God throw the stuff
So he's referring to
prophecy
Okay, I mean that's what happens in Daniel, you know
There's a great stone like a mountain that comes and destroys the image
that Nebuchadnezzar dreamed about and
God set up this that was representative of God's kingdom being set up on earth. So it will literally I
Mean prophecy literally being spoken right here saying that a stone is going to come and destroy
This kingdom right? But I found it kind of interesting because you know
All these little phrases and everything these words all go into everyone's mind. Mm-hmm
in fact
that was the whole reason we made that documentary about how your mind works called sood ology right if you
Understand how the brain works and you sit in a dark room in a theater and open your mind as wide as you can open
You all those words go in there and they stay in there, but you don't think about them
so putting words in people's minds that go and view these movies saying that you know,
God's just gonna throw a stone at you and destroy you is a slam on God once again, right?
Now once again you'll see more biblical imagery here you think you're saving anyone
I turned that key and drop this rock a little early and it's still billions dead. Even you can't stop that
This is the best I can do. This is exactly what I wanted all of you against all of me
How can you possibly hope to stop me so?
Interesting, right? He's literally saying
You guys against me. How do you hope to stop me and we saw in that other previous clip, right?
They wanted to destroy his image
but listen to the end of this film what he is basically describing
when he comes to destroy the world what people are
Looking for what are they doing?
When they're looking up in the sky in the end of the world listen to this verbage. I was meant to be beautiful
More beautiful look to the sky and seen hope seen mercy
Instead they look up and harm because of you so
When he comes to destroy the world people will be looking up into the sky
For hope and mercy, that's the very light the thing that the Christian Church has been longing for
Since the beginning of time, right?
And here's the scene in the very end when he literally is like in the Second Coming pose
Over hovering over the world and listen to what he says to the people
Come to confess your sins. I don't know how much time you got more than you
Have you been juicing this is how you end Tony this is peace in my time. Do you see
the beauty of it
the inevitability
You rise?
only to fall
Isn't this interesting?
You rise only to fall right what's gonna happen with the people at the end of the world?
and
But literally in the very end after Satan sits her for a thousand years thinking about what he's done
the people will be resurrected and
Literally get a chance to see why they weren't allowed to come to heaven only to fall again
Right, very typical even he's in this christ-like pose looking down on the people. It's funny
Is it a slam if it's true?
like all these parallels to
The Bible and it's painting in the light of Nick. This is gonna happen. This is true
It is true, but it is except at the end
It's kind of twisted where the person who has the figure of God falls or as the rebellion wins
Which is incorrect from the biblical standpoint, right? But I just find it interesting going through all of it
It's all true, right? You know what I mean? They're using biblical truth, but they're just flipping the the characters around
Who's the good guy? Who's the bad guy and they're just confusing you but literally they're telling you the truth of what's going on
That's why I found this so fascinating when it kind of really wrapped my head around this 10-year venture that Marvel did
It's been a decade of signs and wonders
And the endgame is
Paralleling what the Bible's telling us is gonna happen in the end. That's what's crazy. Yeah, cuz the viewer wants that guy defeated
That's right. Yeah, he wants the judge or whatever. He wants the ones that they're gonna rise and fall
We wanted to feat the one who's gonna do that. Okay? Okay. So let's talk about Black Panther for a second
This was a massive movie. We made a documentary specifically centered around this film and
There was a lot of spiritualism in this movie. But once again, he's on the side of the Avengers, right?
So we thought it would be appropriate to discuss him in this context
In the very beginning of the Black Panther it's describing how he became the Black Panther
a warrior shaman received a vision from the Panther goddess bust who led him to the heart shaped AB a
plant that granted him superhuman strength speed and
Instincts the warrior became king and the first black panther
What's a shaman say a witch doctor - a witch doctor, right?
someone who uses witchcraft and sorcery and so he
Meets a witch doctor someone who has sorceress powers and he goes and talks with vast an ancient
Egyptian cat God who gives him a piece of fruit to give him superpowers now I can think of another story
Where a animal told you to eat a piece of fruit to give you superpowers. What's that? That's
That's the devil. I mean literally right here every single Christian should have walked out of the movie right here and said hey,
That's the story of the devil
But nonetheless a lot of people still stuck around vast is the ancient Egyptian cat
God and even on Marvel's website it talks about
In this necropolises city the wakandan city of the Dead right? What does necro mean?
the bed
paulus means city
so in the city of the Dead that's where the Black Panthers go to die when you rule there's the king of the Dead I
Mean, this is like the king of the Dead it even says he's an unconquered king of kings lord of lords
I mean those are names that are reserved for God
Yet he's the king of the Dead God is not the king of the Dead. He's the king of the living
That's what I call the Living God. This is opposite of God, right Isaiah 8
19 through 20
Tells us if we're gonna look at the world
Through biblical eyes to the law and to the testimony
If it speaks not according to this word it is because there's no light in them, right?
It has to line up with the Bible. Otherwise, it's not worth your time. That's basically what that st
so let's talk about
when he meets the
his father who's dead and he
Goes through a ritual that sends him into this space where he can then go to to the dead
Panthers and
in here
We have the Panthers sitting inside of the tree and as he approaches the tree the Panther comes down and talks with them
I find it once again, very interesting
That we have a tree and an animal coming down to give you a piece of advice out of that tree
I'll let you sit and think on that for a little bit
Leviticus 20:6 though says and the soul that turneth after such that have familiar spirits after wizards to go whoring after them
I will set my face against that soul and cut him off amongst his people
Listen witchcraft and sorcery is a very serious matter in the bible
You do not as a Christian want God to tell you he's going to set his face against you
God is very merciful
He is very patient, but there are things that will push him past that mercy in patience witchcraft
Look at the stories in the Bible turn through and just read the chapters that happened to the Old Testament
Anyone that constantly struggled with witchcraft and sorcery
They were literally sent out of the camp
And God said this is severe enough don't even have them around you take them outside put them outside of your group
Which of endor story in most cases put to death put to death, right? That's how serious it wasn't the Bible
so
I believe it's a serious then as it is now for us so anything with witchcraft and sorcery turn it off
Don't even watch it, right
In the comic book for Black Panther. Here's Black Panther talking with bast. That's that's closer to Bothell MIT
I mean literally he's going and meeting with Bothell MIT to become the Black Panther and as
He meets with this bast God
That's where bass tells him. You're going to be the king of the Dead and bast
Talks to him and says this line that we read from earlier that you will be
With all of the the past Panthers when they go to die, you'll be a crowned and unconquered King of Kings
I mean those names that are only reserved for God he opens up Black Panthers
Third eye and that's what really gives him the the power to be the Black Panther and then here's the Black Panther
Totally talking to all of the other dead Black Panthers to give them
Council, he says hey, listen, I called upon the name of avast I call upon you for counsel
We're never supposed to call upon the spirits, right?
There's tons of examples in the Bible where people called upon the spirits and it was disastrous
Leviticus 19 31 says do not turn to mediums or necromancer's to seek after them and to make yourselves unclean by them
I am the Lord your God the Bible is very clear on
Necromancy speaking to the dead sorcery witchcraft any of that kind of stuff
It says that it will make you unclean
And if you're a Christian seeking for Christ's righteousness
This is not something that you even want to observe in a film
Now I find it very interesting that after the Black Panther goes and speaks to
that vast looking character
bass tells him that there's coming days a great fire in the sky and
You know
It's like a fire in the sky that's coming to destroy the world looks very much like a second coming but from an evil
perspective right and
It says the great fire will bring about a great flood and then what Condon walls will break the city of the Dead will fall
And that's what the Bible talks about revelation
You know Babylon will fall. There will be a time that this happened. So once again, very interesting parallel, dr
strange, of course
just even
Analyzing the surface of this film. His superpower is black magic, right?
That's why they call him the black magician. He he is very
Much engaged in witchcraft sorcery divination all of those things that the Bible strictly speaks
Against but here's what black magic means
magic invoking the supposed invocation of evil spirits for evil purposes
Now if he's the master of the dark arts, he's the master at invoking evil spirits
For evil purposes. Yeah, he's literally the one that is on the Avengers side
right, so you can start to see that all of these characters like the
Guardians of the galaxy they're the criminals and the thief's they're the black magic sorcerers. They're the
Black Panther kings of the Dead those are all attributes of
Satan or his government or he was cast out of heaven door who's cast out of heaven, right? It's kind of interesting
I know we bring up in one of our documentaries. I think its replacement gods to
Dr. Strange's lair is called the sanctum sanctorum
Which is Latin for Holy of Holies?
Which is where God is supposed to dwell the Holy of Holies, you know, right and that there's evil
invocations of evil spirits being
Invoked in the sanctuary. I mean that's just twisted in and of itself but yes
Deuteronomy 18 10 through 12
Gives us a picture of what sorcery and witchcraft is to God
there shall not be found among you anyone that makes his son or his daughter pass through the fire use earth divination or observer of
Times or an enchanter or witch or a charmer or consulter with familiar spirits or a wizard or a necromancer?
For all that do these things are a what?
Abomination to the Lord, what is the word abomination mean? It's
something that God hates hates
Literally the word abomination is the strongest language that God could use to say I hate this thing
So how is it that we can watch movies with things that are clearly an abomination to God?
What about Captain Marvel?
So we're seeing a common thread run through here right here Captain Marvel
The person that she's fighting against the evil villain in her story is known as the supreme intelligence
Okay, so there here is something that's very interesting as well. Who is the supreme intelligence in the universe?
He is the one that is the top of the food chain
Everywhere, right? He's known as the most wise bean
Looking at it and judging it from a Christian perspective
But this they make this person evil and in the film Captain Marvel
She doesn't really have a form and if you look at the comic books, there are all sorts of different
Interpretations she can kind of manifest herself in different forms
Which I think is very interesting because no man has seen God, right?
So here Captain Marvel is having a discussion with the supreme intelligence. Listen to the verbage that's even used here. There's
Intelligence
Your commander insists that you're fit to serve I am
So once again, we say we see that one of the Avengers is describing herself
And she says I am and it just stops, right?
I find that very interesting that they keep writing that into the dialogue. So let's talk about
the whole
pinnacle of this whole series which really kind of started coming to a culmination in
Avengers infinity war you have this vein called Thanos who's the most evil character in the whole universe is the most
powerful
character in the whole universe
You know is one of the darkest characters in the Marvel Universe a character who can take on the entire Marvel Universe
With a grin there's something really
arch-villain about that and he's specifically running throughout the universe and
collecting stones
that will give him that ultimate supreme power to be able to snap his fingers and wipe out half of the universe and
each one of these stones gives him a different superpower and
I'll tell you what each but some of the stones mean and you can see that there's some very strange parallels to God
One of the stones gives them the ability to have control over space and time
One of them gives them control to create life out of nothing to bend and warp reality
One of the stones gives them the ability to raise people from the dead. I mean, these are these are attributes that are literally only
attributed to God and so as he gets these
Stones and give they give him ultimate supreme power in the universe
He is going to snap his fingers and destroy half of the world and the Avengers are trying to that
So in this scene the Avengers have never actually seen the guardians of the galaxy characters yet
and so this is the first time that they've they've run into the guardians of the galaxy and
They're talking about whose side. Are you on listen to the language that they use down? All right. Let me ask you this one time
What master do you serve master? Do I serve? What am I supposed to say Jesus? Oh
By the way, that's I find extremely blasphemous right? It's like oh it's a joke, like what am I supposed to say?
I serve Jesus like yes
If you're a Christian you serve Jesus and he died for you to have an opportunity to
Passively throw this into a movie. I believe that's taking the Lord's name in vain. Here's an interesting side note Chris
Pratt was awarded at the MTV Movie Awards goes up front and is extremely
Open about his Christian beliefs and he says this
You have a soul
Be careful with it
God is real
God loves you. God wants the best for you believe that I do
Learn to pray
It's easy and it's so good for your soul
Nobody is perfect
People are gonna tell you you're perfect. Just the way you are you're not
You are imperfect
you always will be but
there is a powerful force that designed you that way and if you're willing to accept that you will have grace and
grace is a gift and
Like the freedom that we enjoy in this country that grace was paid for with somebody else's blood do not forget it
Now why I find that interesting is because he was in
The lego movie as the voice of Emmett
If you haven't seen this you got to look at our LED on the whole lego deception
But it was another attack against God and here is an actor who's been part of the guardians of the galaxy
Which is an attack on God and the lego movie which is an attack on God and yet he is not
Shy about his Christian beliefs and he still
Does not see it for what it is. That's how deceptive this stuff really is
So I'm a I'm offended by this kind of thing
I challenge people
Watch a movie and not hear Christ's name blessing. I mean it's in every movie, right?
It seems like every single movie breaks one of the commandments
Right and and because we hear it so often it's not we're not sensitive to it anymore
so anyway, here's has seen with Thanos and
Listen to the language that's used in this
There are two more stones on earth find the my children and bring them to me
I might interject if you're going to us you might want the guy
So, what do you notice that of a scene like this how did he address the people this children and they have addressed him as
father father
Valentin yeah, so these are names and things that are attributed to God and his characters right children
I mean
You never hear the Avengers talk about children to anyone that like follows them, right?
Because that's a name that that literally in the Christian world is attributed to followers of Christ
So err he's talking with Loki he ends up killing Loki and while he's killing him Loki says something very interesting to him
He said you will never be a god and
Remember all the Avengers they consider themselves to be gods, right?
I mean, they always asked about their godlike powers or they are gods are their self-proclaimed gods or there's no doubt
I mean, that's my logic
Neikei - exactly so they're basically like throwing it in God's face
This would be a description of God and saying that you are never going to be a god right? Not the God
Hey God, so I found this very interesting. Here's another IM that pops up in the seam that
Thanos Meets The Avengers listen to how he describes he is coming and he describes himself as the I am I
Asked you to what end?
Read it run from it destiny arrives all the same
And now it's here. What should I say? I?
am
The fact that they highlight it like that
Tells me that that's so purposeful because really he is the real I am all the other ones are counterfeits
Literally of God, right? But in this story, he's in gold. He's the strongest character
He has the ability to wipe out the path the universe. Let me ask you a question
Does Satan have the ability to wipe out any of the part of the universe?
They probably would have already fit in. That's right
Only God has the ability to cause a worldwide flood right now or allow it to happen or wipe it out
That's God's power. No gods holding back the winds, you know so he can only do as much as God
Well Wow, that's right
But even in the end when he lets the winds go the devil is not allowed to kill God's people during that time
so the power is
literally in God's hands that has that ability to begin with so that was very interesting that he says that
Now here's a scene with Thanos and his daughter. He takes children
From all the planets that he's basically taken over and he's wiped out half of their existence. He basically takes
children from there and this is a scene between him and his daughter Gamora and
Notice how she goes and looks at his throne
I hate that thing. Listen to this I
Always hated that chair so I've been told
Even so it said a new one day
So he's basically taking her
Back to where he kind of like rules from
Generally, and that's why she's having this conversation with them and she says it's in his ship
I think and that's why she says I hated that ship. I hate the chair
I hated all these things he writes her to take over after he's gone exactly he wants her to rule, right?
So the ship that she mentions in this is the ship that he comes to destroy the world in and it's called the sanctuary
-
the sanctuary is a
Thing that's attributed to God, right? Yeah, and this is like the I am who's giving his giving his position to his
That's right
The sanctuary - is a massive warship play on words war ship like worship
Right, and that's what he's coming to destroy the world
But here he's having a conversation with some of the Avengers and listen to how he describes when he destroys half the world
What is he going to do after that with all six domes? I could simply snap my fingers
They would all cease to exist and I call that
Mercy
So he calls
Destroying half of the universe what mercy mercy, right?
And so that's that's that's not something that you hear attributed to the devil or his team, right?
It's always attributed to God God is the merciful one but he's saying that wiping half the people out is his mercy, right?
I believe you know
God is going to destroy the wicked because it wants to live for eternity in a world full of rapists murderers. Yeah
It's mercy on his children. He's saving us from those people. That's right
It's merciful for you to not live in a life of sin forever
Harry's having a conversation with dr. Strange and dr. Strange asks and what he's gonna do
And then what?
And I finally rest watch the sunrise on a grateful universe
The hardest choices require the strongest ones
So after he destroys the world what happened press arrests
What happens when God does come at a second coming and destroys?
sinful humanity
There's a time arrest that happens after that
So that's very interesting
There's also another story parallel to God and this story is when Thanos is looking for one of these
Infinity stones and he gets one from this guy here and
In order to get the stone he has to sacrifice one of his children
The stone
demands a sacrifice
Of what?
In order to take the stone, you must lose that which you love the soul
for a soul
Don't you find it interesting that the sacrifice
He's basically saying something that is so true
Sin requires a penalty to be paid for that sin, right?
and here God
sacrificed his own son
To pay that penalty for you and me and who does he end up sacrificing?
his daughter
I'm saying like it's almost like this psychological warfare because when you see these characters
Instantly you think oh bad guy cloak looks like a skull at Grim Reaper looks like death
Yeah, so if you're just watching with your eyes, you're seeing bad guys good guys
But God does not judge on the outward appearance. He judges on the heart the character
So if you if you were just to say who said I then who said I'm the I am who can destroy the universe
He's gonna sacrifice his son all these
Characteristics attributes people would say oh, that's God
but it's painted where you're seeing it as the enemy so, you know, what's kind of crazy is
in this scene where he actually throws his daughter off and
Destroys her fort because he wants the power to be able to destroy half of the planet. So it's not that he literally
Does it because he's like loves everybody right?
he believes that this is the only path to be able to make the universe go forward and so he he like
Does it in a cold-hearted manner? Oh
My life I dreamed of a day
Moment
You got what you deserved
You kill
torture
And you call it mercy
The universe has judged you you failed
Do you wanna know why because you love nothing? No one?
Tears they're not for him
This isn't I
Didn't know what my destiny once
Isn't that crazy? So if they set this up to be a character like God, he heartlessly doesn't care
he's gonna destroy half the universe he calls it mercy but yet everyone else that's viewing him is like you don't care about
anything
Listen, God sent Jesus down here to die your sin my sin
Because he wouldn't spare even the littlest thing in heaven
He gave us the greatest thing in heaven so that you and I could have that opportunity
So opposite of what they're saying right here
I mean, this is like literally if you asked Satan, what's the war in heaven?
Like this is exactly how you'd answer it
You are the cold-hearted one the world in the universe has judged you and found that you love nothing
Ya know that love was proven in the palm of Christ's hands as he hung on the tree
It was Satan that put him there and he didn't deserve it more when Jesus was willing to do that for us
there seems to be a lot of animosity between this father and
Gonna sacrifice you he doesn't care. He's not crying for you. That tear is not for you
That is a slam on God right there
And so as a viewer like you said Ken D as a viewer you watch this and you go yeah
He's evil Dallas is evil and you know what? That's exactly what I found on the internet I read article after article about
atheists that were literally sane
Thanos is the most evil character in the world
and if Thanos is like a god I would never
Serve that type of God and that's what that's what atheists are literally saying, right? And so
Here is a a flipping of that idea and you as a viewer
They psychologically rope you in to try and understand from Thanos perspective
but the end game of what you just watched right there is that you're gonna hate him everyone at first I talked to
This is the way they see God if they don't see them in its true character. They've been seeing this all their life
Yep, and it's the Cetus planet. Yep. There's a reason why they call this programming, right? This is a program. That's
Programming your brain to literally fight and hate God
so that
was the infinity war
Famis ends up in the in it end of infinity war. He snaps his fingers half of everybody dies
So it's like this end of the world scene where people are just dissipating off into the dust of the world. Right? And then
Literally this blew my mind endgame steps on the scene
And this is the trailer to endgame the very first
words that come out of Tony Stark's mouth are this
Cuz he was like a thousand years ago, I fought my way out of that cave became Iron Man
Thousand years ago, it seems like a thousand years why not fifteen hundred years, why not six hundred years?
Why not eight hundred years?
Why do they have to use a number that literally describes how Satan will sit here by himself?
Thinking of what he did for that thousand years and then it takes place after everybody's already gone
It's like they picked up the story Second Coming comes everybody dies
Right, and then now they've picking it up after that thousand years is up and the roles are reversed
You know, he had the attributes of Christ, but he's the one that's stuck on earth for a thousand years
It's like Revelation 20 verse seven after the thousand years have expired gog and magog
come together for the Battle of the great day of the God Almighty, right and
Literally, that's where the story is picking up. You see if you understand
Where the war between God and Satan?
started you can start to begin to wrap your head around what's really truly going on in Ezekiel 28 16 through
17 it talks about
Lucifer this is a prophetic
speech about
Lucifer and it says by the multitude of thy merchandise they have filled the midst of thee with violence and thou has sin therefore
I cast thee out as profane out of the mouths of mountain of God and I will destroy the Oh
Covering cherub from the midst of the stones of fire now question. What is a covering cherub angel?
Whose brother or who does stand in the presence of God and that is symbolized by what?
The Ark of the Covenant right when we had the Ark of the Covenant
those angels whose wings touched over the top of it were that called the covering cherubs and
What's inside of the Ark of the Covenant?
Took my commandments
Aaron's rod that budded in a bowl of manna that's right. So
All of a sudden we have these angels that are literally hovering over protecting the law of God
in fact, it was the very job of the covering cherub in heaven was was to
Share with the world what the character of God was like, that's why
Satan was so damaging when he went around to all the evil angels and he told them you know
What God's really not very loving he's not really nice
They believed him because why the covering cherub is next to God
So as they sat there in and and listened to this person they would say hey wool
Wouldn't you know what God's really like you're you're the one that stands next to him
He was like an insider or whistleblower
He was an insider and that's why he was so effective to bring all the angels with him when he did
Isaiah 14:12 through 14 says how earth have fallen from heaven o Lucifer son of the morning
How art thou cut down to the ground which did weaken the nation's for them has said in thine heart
I will extend my throne upon the stars of God
I will sit upon the Mount of the congregation in the sides of the north
I will ascend into the heights of the clouds and I will be like the Most High now
This makes me question if Satan is saying he wants to be like the Most High. What's God like God?
Is love right fact
that's what the Bible describes God as
so Satan is literally saying I can be loved or loved being just like you but I don't need to follow your rules God and
Obviously we can see what what has happened since then the word devil in Greek
Diablo's means to accuse or bring charges with hostile intent
That's the word devil means to accuse the word Satan in the Greek Satanist means adversary
Or slander the word widespread trade that was used in Ezekiel 28 16. It's called rikku law
Literally means to traffic merchandise or Hetal and that's exactly what the devil's duties peddling lies
About God when you look at the word peddling in the dictionary
it means to travel about and sell something or to engage in the illicit sell of
narcotics to travel about selling wares or to occupy oneself with trifles literally the devil is
Peddling lies about God and he's been doing it from the beginning. So I
Find it very interesting that revelation 12:10
Describes Satan as this I heard with a loud voice saying in heaven now is come salvation and strength
and the Kingdom of our God and the power of his Christ for the accuser of our brethren is cast down, which accused
Them before God day and night
You see the devil only has one trick
In this war between God and Satan
The devil has one trick and every single thing fits under that one trick and the one trick that he does literally is
To represent the character of God in a false light
He can only attack God and attack who he is and attack what he's like and so this war is being played out
so that the whole entire universe will say God is a loving and righteous judge or
Like Satan says they will believe the lies that are told events God
This Marvel Universe that everyone is obsessed with I mean 1.2 billion dollars in a few
Days is so mind-boggling, but you know what? It's the devil's Bible
It's literally the devil's story on
What's going on between the war between God and Satan and it just makes a lot of sense to me why the world?
Gravitated towards it everyone's listening to the lies that the devil is telling. Well, there's a common question
You know, we're looking at this through the eyes of the Bible book with Christians
do you really think you honestly think that the directors of this film all sat together in a room and said hey, you know
Let's attack that's attacked Christianity and and formulate this story to kind of influence and program people against God
okay, so in in the
infinity war there is a
Menu on the DVD if you buy the DVD the blu-ray DVD
There's actually a whole commentary between the directors and in that commentary the directors
themselves said that Thanos is a
Godlike character that has a messianic complex
Hmm you don't use those kind of words or that kind of terminology unless you know something literally even if they
Don't know what's going on. Right? We know that God can suggest things to us. Just like the devil can suggest things to us
so I
Believe that if people are
opening themselves up to the
Spirit world, right? The devil can come in and give them ideas and they can go. Oh wow
I came up with this really great idea for a Marvel Cinematic character. Right and it has all this common congruent, you know
Common denominators with God right? But maybe they didn't sit around and just say hey
I think that's God when Jesus told the story about casting the demon out of the man's mind and
The the demon went away and the man swept up his mind and he came back and checked on the man and he found that
the man had left his house
Empty wasn't filled
Then the demon went out and he got seven more unclean spirits and he came back and the man was worse off than he was
Before what that tells me is we are empty vessels
You were either filled with the Spirit of God
Or if you're empty
you open yourself up for the devil to come in and the devil is not going to knock on the door of your heart and
Say, excuse me. Can I come in? He's gonna come right in he's gonna bring his friends
They're gonna post up and have a great time in your mind, right?
So I think that these people that are coming up with some of these storylines maybe don't realize they're being used
By the devil and that's why we see this common denominator
But my question to them would be if there's a hundred and one million things to talk about why you always gravitating towards this
Why does every evil character share a common trait with God? Why is there always biblical language environment? Why on this rock?
I will build my church
Why would you even say that in the line music and in the directors a lot of them say?
I got this script from a dream a vision, you know
and then like Grant Morrison and the other guy they were I mean Grant Morrison he's
Into the magic. He's like
Making symbols and sitting in the middle of them and telling them that telling people that demons are telling me to write this stuff
Okay, I drank it's not like they're using the Quran at the Baha'i Gita or any night text
Why doesn't he use Muslim words? Yeah, why doesn't he use, you know, like some Buddha words or whatever. He like, you know, it's like
they're they're literally using the words that are attributed to God or Jesus said or whatever and to me that's just twisting the
Idea of who God is you'd have to be pretty ignorant to think that it's all just coincidence or pointless. That's right. That's right
and I mean when you see it even outside of
Let's say this world like the Marvel Universe like the one we did on Star Wars, right?
You can look it up on YouTube. See our video on Star Wars. You'll see the exact same formula
it's being used there is common traits that that are between God and Satan and they're just
Flipping the idea where God is evil and darth vader is the evil one
But yet he's more like Jesus than he is like the devil would be like Darth Vader
so
You know these things I think are slid in these movies for a reason and I think there's a reason why we're pointing these out
and saying listen
You've got to know the truth. The only way you can spot these things is by studying the truth
you're not gonna sit down and watch a movie like this and be all of a sudden like I know what the truth is and
I can see everything that they're doing
Unless you have a relationship with God once you do you hear buzzwords like that. Like I'll build my house upon this rock
Then all of a sudden you're like hey wait
I remember that from my Bible and you know what the truth is and you'll finally I believe get to the point where
Well, I want to want to watch a movie that slams my god
I don't want to why would I want to do that? Even if it's cool?
I could find what better ways to spend my time
So what do you guys think? The end result is for the Christian and non-christian what?
Why do you think Hollywood is pushing these particular themes over and over and over again?
You want to know what the end result is. This is the end result right here. Ok
2nd Thessalonians 2 9 through 12 says this the coming of the lawless one will be in accordance to how Satan works
Now pause, what does it mean to be lawless?
Rebel against God's come now. Follow the laws, right?
So we know that the Bible speaks that there will be a time in the end
Where a lawless one will be in accordance to how Satan operates what they're doing is they're setting people up
There is a division that is happening right here
You are either a follower of God, or you will be a follower of Satan. There will be a time that there is no
middle ground
Those wheat and those tears are growing up together and I believe that separation is beginning to be seen now
so if you constantly watch
Erroneous things you train your brain to focus on the errors or to digest the errors and not be able to discern truth
So listen to what the Bible says he will use all sorts of displays of power through signs and wonders
That serve the lie and all the ways that wickedness deceives those who are perishing
They perish because they receive a refuse to love the truth and so be saved. So how do people lose their salvation?
Another focuses your love the truth. They don't love the truth. So my idea is
When you watch all of these errors all the time, you totally lose your discernment for truth
The devil's gonna step on the scene and deceive people we know that prophetically from the Bible in the end of the time
He it's like his master
Opus
Plan is like one more last-ditch effort to try to get as many people on his side as possible and the people that get deceived
Get deceived because they don't love the truth the better, you know
The truth the better you won't be too
For this is the reason that God sends them a powerful delusion that they will believe the lie
So God even has to allow this separation to happen
And so that all will be condemned who have not believed the truth
But have delighted in wickedness and let's be honest don't these movies look wicked?
Isn't it full of wickedness killing murder, you know?
Sexual immorality you name it? All of that wickedness is in these movies
Why?
They're getting darker and darker and and and you know
What's crazy is when I see little kids running around that I've seen all these things
dressed like a black panther I
Believe it is high time
No, your master learn to have a relationship with Jesus and how you do that is by studying and getting familiar with the
very source of truth the Holy Bible
Thank you guys for listening I hope that this was beneficial to you, you know, leave a comment in here
We want to hear from you guys
We're excited to put this show out LED live if you want to support us check out our patreon page
we've got a lot of cool perks out there and
God bless you guys and subscribe if you want to see more videos just like this